今日はやらああ
今日は弾み雪のでやっぱり保留中バーとか動画を出していると何やかやですねそのいい
声ばかりではないんですよアンチとかその悪口言う人とかはい数とかからいろんなこと
をバッシングと歩んで保護されてそれでもとーっても中まで続けてきてこれだと言い
ますと
見てないんですよと結局みんな気するんですよ悪口とか誹謗中傷とかて論ぽい事を言わ
れてちょっと
落ち込むとかそういうことは何年も聞かなければ何でも感じない
最後どうか菜好牛中なんだい本年気にせずやってこれるんですよ逆に応援してくれてる
人とかいい事言ってくれる人のことだけ聞いてたらほんとハッピーなんでしょ
ドライバーだがそのだけだ俺もう進化できねぇたまにはあまり今もアンチという感じに
悪くとソニャなくを言ってくる人たちの意見もちゃんと聴いてみて
もうさぁなるしてトップ夏を乗り越えて更にステップアップに向かって今日は前の動画
で募集した
悪口誹謗中傷いろんな意見を全部
身体で受け止めると思います宜しくお願いします
why で光栄ですけどはこれはまだまだしげズ
よいやーよろしくねさんおいはじめちゃん超
良平先生を3カ月ではっきりを太らせるとかやばすぎだろう
大食いバック企画しないで2の体調管理もしっかりしろよ
カッコマジですはいいいですか畑の大外企画はほとんど黒考えてません
パワーを得始めて面性格
外は髪の毛染めで金髪になるは一時期動画で炎上して休んでたはサブチャンネル作れば
パン倶楽部作るはもうも多くがなくなったはどうしてくれるんだ
いざか褒めてないセックス会社の子っていうと者色々ありましたら元気に合わせて
いただいております
宜しくお願もやしが白衣なんだ切れてる気もいたらお前のせいでウンチが漏れそう
白黄色企画やてくれ一緒に入れちゃうんだよ
それできないんですよ受けろ
好きなんですよ黄色が好きなげない議論泊の見てると楽しくないですか
そうでもない人もいるんでちょっと何も言えないですけどために履きましていません
ただ白馬里ズレに言っておきます動画の最初で肇社長殺したりして対応をはじめ
昔みたいに暴れ回って女子ローよニベア風呂しちまえよ
金髪にしたのは褒めてやる歌は
ますを受けたはい
そういう取り出すっていう生上がれたいのは山々なんですけど
25よ日中もの暴れてたら本在勤動画な距離願い如実に下がったよどうぞよしてるよ
はじめの動画見る気にならねーよ昔みたくに行ってくれ
みーてんじゃねーかー始めたどうかを問題視邪魔なんだけどめっちゃ努力者大威張りに
行く
の動画滑りパクるしはらたつ嫌いすぎてサムネだけでは基礎
ダラダラしてさ全然おもんねーな
そしてはた強みにしたらなんかなっていない始め好きですになっています
うわぁね多分ドッキリが多くて後輩がかわいそうです
いいか
ドッキってかなやっても怒られない信頼関係の上に成り立っているものなドッキリは
はいなんだよこれ以上を課金するのやめろいや0
いいかアプリ純やってるところな解散ではもう家私何もなんだよ
課金は悪いことじゃないんだよああ
your song 飛び出すテープに謝れ
すいませんですね
なんてねスキルだめだこりゃ私生活も
ということである何を叩く通って強い思えないんですよ俺の人を選んだし何が違う
分かったのか
俺の子の気持ちになるよなんだよ少しいたししたから遊び心ずれたんかああこれは中学
生の時コーラに蛇口つけても
のもう撮った源さんに時
4桁の今はなんか折ったりしてないかもっとはクラレはそんなに昔通りが好きなら
村の動画ミラー声も飽きてる整体潰したいです
[音楽]
すいませんでした山で兄日に謝れどうでもいいけどいい歳なんだから早く結婚しろイオ
今季のバス増
ちなみにも浮気はスレだよ
秋外しませんだから
本当に結婚できないと思ってる凄く
それぞれ
スタッフ m ですねうーん
me
oppo 2時過ぎて草
つがいいたしました流子の口当たりがポッポに見てると呼びますだけ
ぽに謝れ初めは引きこもりオタク燃やして昔の方が動画面白かったし炎上とか全然記事
内で本当に自分の好きなことして生きてるかあったし
他のユーチューバーたちとも和気あいあいとしている感じがすごい良かったのに今は
日記になって本
茶の湯中バー等ともコラボしなくなったし仕方ないから持ったけど
炎上のことと課金している間すごいからぶっちゃけ面白くなくなった
安保琢磨八潮変わらないけど未だ初めは今の初めだから昔のことをああだこうだ言うつ
じゃあはこっちには1ミリもないけどやっぱり昔の生き生きしていたはじめがなんだか
大一番好きだった
他ありがとうございますまぁ色々言いたいことあるんですけど規模がでかい者
他のユーチューバーとは木や石なくなったのはー
俺のせいじゃないユーチューバーがみんな東京に集まって俺だけ静岡で頑張ってるから
どっちかというと
パブられてんだよ t 社様だせーんだよ気持ち悪いなぁ
あっにゃれ委員長が避け打ってるー
[音楽]
失礼致します
すると主張したトマトいじるのやめろ毎日見てて僕はいいと思うねじられてて可哀相な
んだよ
いじられて嫌な奴に youtube をよろしくは姉とまだねーじゃねーか松そうに
見える
はぁっ
スムーズに楽しんでよ楽しいああっだなぁ
強いほども多いようバーみたいな狩りもやし野郎が調子乗っててムカつくから住所晒し
といてやるよ
静岡県静岡市葵区長沼って感じじゃなきゃいけないと大胆あれだけで全部です代金1塁
側よりもクズ人でやってる動画が多すぎて昔の動画が恋しいぞ
く僕がもやしをもっともっと見てんだよ
の気持ちはわかります根本的な話をすると僕やっぱり一人が好きなんですよ
梱包までもう水もう1個は実は建物を借りるんであ衝撃発表してますね実はもう行く
建物苅部んでそこではずメインを取るペア
もう一つねで畑を取るにあってもちょっと区分するでいい感じの1人ぼっち会が動く
twitter のされると思いますよ私の彼氏のま
をやめてくださいいろんな人に初めに顔が似てると言われます私は初めに興味があり
ませんか
乗ってる車がはじめと同じだったりパズドラバカだったり
いう行カード大好きだったり極度の人見知りだったりいろんなところが似てるんです日
は目付は彼氏がお菓子の花のチョコを食べてこれウメんだよと言った次の日に
はじめもバナナ
って運命よなってツイートしたことがあって結構リアル流行多かったです
彼氏にこの事を言うとあいつが真似してるんだよと言います
なので初め私の彼氏の真似をするのはやめてください
晴れの羽ばたくしてくれた
こわいなカメ子さん本当に申し訳ございませんですただ間に合わせねえ
度仲良くシュネルのじゃない cad さすぎる最近つまら昔みたいに思いっきり上げ
彼女をそう一人どうせ彼女のエロい動画1本でいいからさせ
北海にディアブロ子をあの麺と数ロンギヌスの会話撮り直せまた言いながらいろいろい
好きな段取りは
止めてくれ金髪うんちっち金髪金髪分ちっ
原発乳金髪父を教え
僕はこれはじゃないですよ
me
ana あった